all right well thank you for coming
tonight
welcome to the the last lecture in this
series this summer summer fever of the
2011 Hertog global strategy initiative
so I'd like to thank as I always do
Rodger Hertog and the Hertog foundation
for making all this possible I want to
also thank the mailman School of Public
Health
both the Center for the history and
ethics of public health but also I want
to thank the communications department
for all their support
I want to thank as well since this is
the last lecture all of those who have
been helping all along to make all this
possible and that especially it's a case
with Sidney gross thank you so much to
me so if you've been coming to these
lectures you know that these lectures
are a part of a larger program and
includes a research program there's a
seminar at this there are elective
courses there's a lot that we're trying
to do to pack in every summer and so
we've drawn on the talents of many
others as well so I want to also thank
will Leonard if he's here thank you so
much well I want to thank Lydia Walker
it's also played a key role Thank You
Lydia and I also want to thank Andrew
and Chang and Amina the the interns
who've joined us later in the summer
about
but if volatility mand their talents and
their intelligence and and and all these
waves made this program better than it
might have been so thank you again the
idea behind this program is that we're
trying to take on problems that are
transnational in nature and global and
scope
and we're trying to see whether it's
possible to do a historical research on
some of the most pressing problems in
world politics and think too about how
it is history might help us to plan for
and prepare for these challenges so this
is a program that while its historical
in nature and in the sense of the kind
of research we do the archives we go to
the interviews we conduct the kinds of
people who come to us and and tell us
about what they've learned over the
course of their careers and in the
research that they've done it's also one
that tries to bring in people from
different disciplines to help us as
historians better understand the nature
of these kinds of problems last year's
nuclear proliferation this summer it's
on pandemics in public health next
summer we'll be looking at religious
violence and apocalyptic movements so
we're taking on some of the biggest
problems in world politics we're trying
to do basic research and we're trying to
do it in a way that's actually relevant
and maybe even useful for thinking about
these problems and trying to do
something about them so in bringing
people together we're also bringing
together undergraduates and graduate
students undergraduates are doing very
advanced research as I've been hearing
and as others of you already know over
the last three days and the
presentations that they've done and
graduate students as well who I think in
part because it's the summertime and all
the adults are away including their
advisers they're able to ask questions
that in some ways may be our bigger and
bolder they've been they've been trained
to to take on in the course of doing say
a dissertation they're doing all that in
the course of the summer instead of in
six years and I assure you the results
is you'll be seeing in the publications
that they will produce I think have been
quite exciting but let me welcome Allan
Brant in particular and and thank him
for coming because in many ways the work
that he's done has been a model for many
of us in this program not only in the
the path-breaking and incredibly
important books that he's written
the cigarette century and also a no
magic bullet but asking very basic
questions about how we understand
agenda-setting and in public health how
it is that problems in public health
help to create a prism by which we can
better understand society but also
because of the kind of the ways of its
he's used this research to inform public
debates on the most important issues of
life and death for millions of people
for instance in the way that he
testified for the US Department of
Justice in the US vs Philip Morris and
in many other ways that I won't tell you
about and he would be much too modest to
tell you about but which you could read
about if you just begin to research Alan
Brown and then finally is the Dean of
the Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
at Harvard Allen as he's been telling us
has been doing really exciting things in
graduate education and I want to thank
him too for talking to our students
about some of those things and helping
them think critically as we all must
about the history and future of public
education and higher education in the
United States so in all these ways I
want to thank Alan and I want to thank
him too for preparing this exciting
lecture on history health and global
governance the case of the Framework
Convention of tobacco on tobacco control
so thank you again Ellen thank you very
much Thank You professor Connelly and
for such a great introduction and I want
to thank you and professor Morse and
especially Sidney grosse for inviting me
and having me here today when I got the
invitation from you in the spring I have
to say as I've read about the program I
got excited right away because these are
the questions that have been so
essential to me personally about how we
find a usable past how to think about
the history of contemporary problems how
to try to do serious scholarship but
scholarship that also is related to
crucial questions of the present and the
future and I just have to say getting to
talk with the students who participated
in the program this summer you know how
excited I am for the kinds of work that
you're doing it's really a remarkable
program and it has all the right values
because I'm somebody who believes in
knowledge for knowledge sake but at the
same time I'm also somebody who believes
that the kind of work we can do in our
scholarship can really be related to the
most powerful moral and cultural
political questions of our time and
figure out how to do that in a way that
really has rigor and is done in a
systematic way something I'm still
struggling with so what I thought I
would do is is tell you about a problem
that I struggled with in my recent work
on tobacco and I think it will raise a
lot of questions about things that
you've been studying all summer and
maybe we can have a broader conversation
about some of those questions we just
came from a smaller seminar and I was
explaining when I came to Columbia to do
my graduate work in 1975 I thought I
would work on comparative questions
across nations and I was immediately
told either you're an American is tour
Europe you're a Europeana stand a lot of
American history has centered on the
question of how is America so different
and I have to say unfortunately that's
the tradition in which I was taught and
Americanist really worked on America as
if it was unconnected from the world and
so many the questions at stake in
thinking about global history
I mean placing America within a broad
global context in the kinds of
transnational exchanges that Professor
Connelly just mentioned and that's
really the theme that I want to take up
today but I have to admit even when I
started my book on cigarette smoking I
really thought I was gonna write a
history of cigarette smoking in American
life and that I would trace a rather
remarkable story of how cigarette
smoking came to be so popular in the
United States and then ultimately about
its relative decline in the last two or
three decades and I thought that was a
great story for the most part smoking
doesn't exist as we know it as recently
as 1900 there was this phenomenal rise
of cigarette smoking during the course
of the 20th century in the United States
and then a very good story for public
health that a behavior that's highly
addictive that's intensely advertised
and so on actually declines in number
over a series of decades that that would
be sort of beginning middle of an end
and that's really where I started I just
thought I would briefly review some of
the questions that were at stake in this
this is just a chart that shows the rise
of male smoking very intense in the
first decade of the of the 20th century
often associated with World War one the
women's Christian Temperance Union
opposed smoking and said now that we've
banned alcohol will ban smoking but by
the end of the First World War the
women's Christian Temperance Union is
distributing cigarettes to the troops so
there's a profound social and cultural
change that takes place during the war
tremendous rise in men's smoking and
then followed about a 20-year lag in
women smoking almost getting to the
rates in which men smoked and this was
really the chart that I began my project
with I wanted to explain this and I
thought there are so many important
questions to American social cultural
historians historians of medicine and
public health that that would be my
project but it turned out not exactly to
be the case but what I thought I would
do is just quickly show you sort of some
of the factors that led to that rise in
cigarette smoking and just mention it
because I always had the notion that if
we could understand why cigarette
smoking got to be so popular in the
United States you would recover some of
the mechanisms for undoing that behavior
that there was almost perhaps a form of
reverse engineering in a historical
project like this that to really
understand what types of public health
interventions might be most effective
today around smoking you really had to
understand how its appeal was built up
in the early years of the 20th century
there are many aspects of this changes
in biz
and business organization that I
described in my book changes in
technology and the mass production of
cigarettes people went from rolling
several hundred a day to machines that
could roll hundreds of thousands in an
hour and then how do you mass market a
product that you can produce so easily
and cheaply but branding was a critical
aspect and the emergence of national
brands is at the heart of consumer
cultures and camels was one of the first
major brands these ads are from right
around the time of the first world war
one of the big issues that the chart
that I showed you already raises is men
started smoking but there was a
widespread perception in American
culture in the first decades of the 20th
century that it was not appropriate for
women to smoke so the companies realized
we've only got half the market and so
how are we going to change cultural
norms to think about getting women to
smoke when there are serious moral
social and cultural prescriptions about
women smoking and especially women
smoking in public the reason I want to
raise this so so clearly now is that
when we look at smoking globally today
smoking is principally around the world
a male behavior and I know what that
means to the tobacco industry it means
we're missing major segments of the
market and they had a specific strategy
in the United States to getting women to
smoke in these early decades of the 20th
century that now we're seeing deployed
again in very culturally nationally and
historically specific ways one of the
ways they did it here is they said well
we can't really advertise directly to
women so let's have these ads that say
have a woman saying blow some my way
this is these ads are from 1928 and
right away Chesterfield became the most
popular cigarette among women's smokers
American tobacco hired this very
brilliant public relations expert on
your left Edward Bernays and he actually
hired debutantes to smoke in the
nineteen
Easter Day Parade in New York and
Bearnaise is really a fascinating figure
in the history of consumer cultures and
his papers are at the Library of
Congress in Washington and so when I
started this project I went down there
and they said well his papers won't
become available until he dies and I
said well how old is he and they said
well he's 98 so I waited and I waited
and historians can be quite ghoulish in
this way and Bearnaise died at a hundred
and three and the next day I was at the
National Archives and what I found was
really curious is that he had collected
scrapbooks with newspaper articles and I
kept asking myself the question that a
historian should about documents why is
he collecting these scrapbooks of
newspaper articles because he did not
want to identify that he had been
involved in the production of these news
stories but what he wanted to do was to
create news and then documented the way
he could demonstrate this for his client
in this instance American tobacco was by
collecting all the news clippings and at
the time there were news clippings
services many of you have worked in
archives have seen these kinds of
collections he documented that when he
got the debutantes to smoke Lucky
Strikes on Fifth Avenue at the 1928
parade he made sure that there were news
photographers there to do it and he said
controversy this will create women
smokers women smoking in public he
associated it with feminism and women's
liberation at the moment and was all
incredibly effective you see this ad on
your right I really don't know if I
should smoke but my brothers and my
sweetheart smoked and it does give me a
lot of pleasure there's a transformation
at this moment in American culture about
the idea that pleasure is indulgent and
wrong to actually creating a pleasure
oriented economy where it says indulge
in a Lucky Strike the most pleasurable
cigarette and I noticed this
transformation in American culture
around items like the cigarette at this
time these are ads that were Bernays ads
do you inhale everybody's doing
seven out of ten smokers inhale
knowingly the other five inhale
unknowingly the the use of sexuality to
sell products seems apparent here some
of my students think that these are
sexually suggestive I don't see it
myself these were actually drawn by a
famous pinup artist of the 1930s but by
by this time women and men are smoking
equally it's seen as a sign of relations
between men and women smoking becomes
very popular in American film one of the
questions I got all the time as I was
beginning this project was does the
smoking you see in American film as a
visual representation reflect changes in
the culture
don't you see smoking in film because
more people were smoking but when we get
into the tobacco documents you see that
Bernays was working with Hollywood
directors and with major film companies
to assure that they used cigarettes in
their film so the relationship between
film as a cultural idiom and force and
industrial interests is much more
complex than simply seeing it as a
mirror of changing culture so the other
thing that became so apparent during
this period of the rise of cigarettes is
that cigarettes turned out to be
extremely dangerous and so one of the
things that I have studied is the rise
of the science of Epidemiology as it was
reflected in the cigarette some of my
friends have said you don't need to be
an epidemiologist to see the causal
relationship here but what I want to
suggest is as early as the 1930s and 40s
when people became very concerned about
cancers and tobacco this relationship
would have been much more difficult to
unpack and so the very early years of
epidemiologists looking at this question
looks like this and so one of the things
we know about tobacco is that the
knowledge in certain disciplines that
were that evolve were crucial to the
determination of evidence-based notions
of causality and disease which is
critical to so many material questions
in global health and so I don't have to
to go into the detail now but the early
evolution of retrospective and then
prospective trials to unpack this
particular question is a crucial element
of mid twentieth century science and the
development of Epidemiology as a field
and I like showing this slide when I
teach in schools of public health
because it really puts you back in a
moment where some of the tools that we
use just normally now weren't always
available and how do you understand this
question you see a small rise in disease
but is it caused by the rise in
automobiles the paving of roads which is
highly toxic the development of
cigarette smoking which is a major
popular behavior or some other variable
and understanding I think epidemiology
at that level is crucial to thinking
about the skill set that's really needed
to unpack very complicated problems of
causality here's how the tobacco
industry responded to scientific
knowledge more doctors smoke camels than
any other brand when I testified against
the tobacco industry in the case that
Matt mentioned I had found out that
actually what they were doing is they
would go to medical meetings and put
Camel cigarettes in the doctors rooms
then they would have a pollster in the
lobby and the poster would say doctor
what cigarette brand are you carrying
and then fish out this free pack of
camels and then they said more doctors
smoke camels than any other brand I was
telling a story at the trial and like 30
tobacco lawyers got up all at one time
and said we object
we're stipulating to this story we don't
want to hear a hit so I thought it's a
pretty good story the other types of
responses were to say you know filter
cigarettes or our cigarettes don't
really cause disease and a lot the
reason I show these slides in this
context is a lot of these issues are
persistent safer brands ultralights a
lot of issues that had that have been
very difficult from a public health
point of view really have their origins
in the 50s around the definitive
evidence that smoking causes lung cancer
what the companies did they put out at
this statement that again was planned by
public relations people that said we've
always been committed to public health
we want to get to the bottom of this
there's a great deal of scientific
uncertainty around the problem of
cigarette smoking rely on us to get to
the bottom of this and so this remains
part of the strategic orientation that
I'll describe more about the tobacco
industry in a in a global context
finally the Surgeon General of the
United States in 1964 came forward and
said cigarette smoking causes lung
cancer and it really required the state
and one of the questions that we want to
ask I think when we're thinking about
global health is what is the appropriate
role of the state in this instance the
state adjudicated a controversy that had
been invented by the industry and the
state was recognized as a neutral player
in the resolution of that dispute even
though the industry would be deeply
committed to undermining the findings of
the first Surgeon General's report often
through political lobbying the first
label on cigarettes after Surgeon
General Terry makes his announcement
that cigarette smoking causes lung
cancer was a label that the industry
wanted on cigarettes that said cigarette
smoking may be hazardous to your health
now why did the industry want that on
the package it was viewed as a public
health intervention because then they
could say cigarettes are labeled you're
aware that they may be harmful and the
decision is yours
so you cannot hold our companies
responsible so there's a very ambiguous
history to labeling in which we think of
it as a public health intervention but
in this instance it very much served the
interests of the tobacco industry and
I'll say a bit more about that a little
bit later on so here we have this chart
and I have to say in my American
Exceptionalist orientation I viewed this
chart with some degree of gratification
that cigarette smoking had grown
tremendously I thought I had some
explanations for why that was the
that I understood it better as I
conducted my study and I began to
understand why cigarette smoking had
declined modestly but significantly
given its biologically and socially and
culturally addictive qualities and I
thought this is a good story for public
health where you identify health risks
even in the face of powerful industrial
interests and yet you create a society
that begins to modify it and we went
from as you see almost 60% of men I
recently saw a data point that in
medical schools in the mid-1960s nearly
80% of all medical students were regular
smokers imagine that today and yet today
we see these dramatic declines in
medical schools you know you would have
fewer than 1% of medical students are
smokers today so it was a good story but
here's my point in the context of
thinking about global health this good
story of American public health and the
nature of what we understand about
tobacco has had dramatic implications
for global health and so we need to
think about this story in a much more
complicated way because one of the
things I think it will teach us is that
an intervention that may be successful
in one nation-state has all kinds of
very serious implications for other
nations and for indices of global health
and that's really where I want to take
off today so one of the questions that I
think we really need to ask when we tell
a story of success in public health is
what were its ramifications in terms of
some of the transnational and relational
issues that are really at the core of
how to think about global health and one
of the big problems that we have right
now is how are we going to define global
health is it just everything that
happens relating to health on the globe
or can we be somewhat more specific
about the kinds of human and disease
interactions and movement that actually
crosses societies and States in ways
that might be informed by different
types of public policies and that's at
the heart of what I really wanted is
that's what the companies realized and
they realized it early on was that what
was happening in the United States and
the growing awareness of tobacco as the
principle public health risk that
Americans were experience experiencing
made them think about other markets and
I have to think that that the tobacco
industry has been remarkably intelligent
and sophisticated about the overall
decline in American smoking that they
anticipated as early as the 1970s and
they began to aggressively think about
where are other markets that will create
what they refer to in their own
documents as replacement smokers they
said American smokers are quitting or
they're dying and if we are going to
sustain our industry we need new smokers
and where will new smokers come from
they'll either come from kids today in
the United States and other Western
developed countries who don't smoke but
given the levels of affluence and
education and the public health
campaigns and especially the campaigns
about sidestream smoke that became so
important by the 70s and 80s the United
States market the Western European
market the Australian and Canadian
markets for example are all going to be
compromised so where is the future of
our product and it was really in the
developing world and so this in a way is
the problem in the year 2000
approximately four million people died
of tobacco-related diseases worldwide
and half of them were in the developed
world and half of them were in the
developing world low income in some
middle-income countries and by the year
2030 now only less than two decades from
now the number of total deaths will go
from four million to 10 million it will
more than double
but those desk will occur predominantly
very significantly 70% of those deaths
will now occur
in the developing world and this is the
material representation of a tobacco
industry strategy that was really
hatched in the 60s and 70s in terms of
finding new smokers and aggressively
promoting smoking in places that had
lower levels of literacy and education
which had weaker state governments which
had no regulatory regimes and I'll say a
bit more about that I don't know if if
you've used these maps in the course
have used some of these these are really
fascinating maps and I I highly
recommend that you go on this website
it's called world mapper org and these
come from the University of Sheffield in
England but a cartographer they're
working with a physicist from the United
States worked out a distortion map in
which you could enter a single variable
and distort landmass by that variable
and so they have literally hundreds of
these maps on the website maternal
mortality education a lot of health
outcomes a lot of social indicators and
they put in one variable and then the
map distorts and what this does is it
really tells you where where that
variable is most active at any one time
I have to say this was surprising to me
and I've been studying tobacco for a
long time to realize that there's so
much smoking going on in Russia and the
former Soviet Union in India and
Southeast Asia and just how how reduced
smoking is in North America how it has
not been so predominant in Latin America
and you know I feel in my work I've
gotten inside the head of the tobacco
industry and as I say they're very
sophisticated they see this map and they
say what are some of the opportunities
on this map and a giant opportunity is
Africa and Latin America where
individuals tend to be less well
educated and in which you can create a
new market given you know
consumer economies so it's it's pretty
impressive
here it is for women and so you can see
there are many places that for men have
tremendous numbers of smokers but look
at the difference between India or the
Russian states on this and you and you
and you see that is an opportunity and
what I learned in my study is if you're
a tobacco executive and you're thinking
where's our weakness it's on women
smokers in India then they become very
sophisticated and they know a lot about
this and they actually did this in the
United States in the 1920s and what are
the associations of getting women to
smoke there around equality under
equality women in the workplace women as
attractive and glamorous so a lot of the
building blocks for addressing this from
if you will the dark side are really
expressed in these material maps and you
can learn a lot from these maps very
quickly here's what's been happening
smoking is on the decline in the US and
the UK it's been on a very steep incline
on in China the Great British
epidemiologist Richard Peto did a major
study of the epidemiology of smoking and
smoking harms in China he said if the if
the Chinese smoke like the American and
the British they'll die like the
American and the British and this is an
enormous problem for the health care
system in China but it's also indicative
of some of the questions that I want to
raise about markets and commerce from a
global perspective
here's he'd tobacco related deaths per
year and China by 2040 will eclipse all
of the developed nations in terms of
numbers of deaths
that's an evolving healthcare system how
will putting this number of chronic
related diseases that we associate with
smoking into that system impact the
emerging Chinese economy
in the middle of the 21st century I
think this is a very clever illustration
so I wanted to share it with you this is
from Alan Lopez and what he's done is he
has put various areas of the world into
different stages of what he would call
tobacco epidemics or the tobacco
pandemics and so you see Western Europe
the United Kingdom the US Canada in
Australia having declining smoking rates
and they're in the fourth stage after
very significant rises in the middle of
this chart Eastern Europe and southern
Europe have plateaued Latin America but
sub-saharan Africa China Japan South
East Asia are really steeply rising and
so you can in a way develop some periods
of this epidemic but one of the things
this raises for us is is there something
that we could learn from what the
Western European or American history of
the epidemic that we could guide back
into stage 1 and stage 2 countries so
that they would have stronger tools to
resist this rise of smoking and so these
are some of the questions of governance
that I think we get into in policy is
what do we know from our experience in
the West that might be utilized
effectively in other places of the world
at this time and it's that transfer of
knowledge that's a critical aspect of
globalization as well this has
tremendous implications for the overall
burden of disease and I don't know how
much some of you have spent on overall
concepts of the burden of disease and
how its measured but it's a critical
element and we've actually made a lot of
progress in coming to more consensual
measures about the burden of disease in
societies in the last 20 years but what
I wanted to suggest by this complicated
slide which I'll try to explain is that
in developing countries the predominant
aspect of the burden of disease have
become non communicable diseases and so
we're dealing in the West
with systemic chronic diseases heart
disease the diseases associated with
obesity the cancers that are a very
significant component of our burden of
disease with a minority of disease
outcomes impacted by infection in the
developing world they're still dealing
with fundamental epidemics of infectious
diseases tuberculosis and malaria tend
to be highly prevalent what this will do
in those countries is that rather than
having what we call a traditional Health
transition which we saw in most Western
countries from periods of epidemic
infectious diseases to systemic chronic
diseases they will have a simultaneous
burden of infectious disease and
systemic chronic diseases for those who
survive infectious disease and this
double burden is double jeopardy will
have a tremendous impact on the health
systems of developing countries that are
often resourced poor when it comes to
developing access to health services so
the changes in the use of tobacco will
severely impact developed countries
here's what's going on now as many of
you know Altria or Philip Morris USA was
split from Philip Morris International
and Philip Morris Altria sales even
though its profits are increasing but
sales are essentially flat in the West
but this is the numbers of cigarettes
that Philip Morris International is
manufacturing and selling now so the
entire shift of this industry has gone
from the west to the developing
countries in the most dramatic ways in a
relatively brief period of time so there
is a tremendous potential for the a
colossal epidemic of tobacco-related
diseases one things we know about
tobacco is unlike so many other risky
harmful substances it causes so many
different diseases and so much more bida
t so it is just a highly toxic
that has so many negative health
outcomes and no no benefit on the other
side there are some there are some risks
that at least have some potential
benefits on the other side this is what
the global market share of tobacco looks
like now obviously the China tobacco
monopoly continues to produce a
tremendous number of cigarettes and sell
them but here you see British American
Tobacco and Philip Morris are together
much more significant than even the
China National tobacco monopoly what the
tobacco companies have been doing in
places like this ad in Nigeria are
finding ways to aggressively promote
cigarettes in countries that are highly
vulnerable to initial sales and
initiation of tobacco and you see here
one of the things they did at this event
is they lit cigarettes and gave them to
people coming to the movies one of the
things have done at a lot of
discotheques in Southeast Asia is you
need to return empty packages in order
to get access to the discotheque so
these are practices that obviously you
know if people tried them in New York
City now would be illegal but there's a
there's a regulatory map you might say
that the industry has and they're
looking for countries where regulatory
processes are at there are at their very
most limited these are ads let me tell
you where these come from one second
sorry these are from Senegal Kenya and
Nigeria these are all either British
American or or Philip Morris products
this is the kind of advertising you see
in Ukraine on the upper left Pakistan
China Senegal and Cambodia
now this is very interesting these are
these are photographs from Thailand and
Thailand bans cigarette advertising in
1988 and it's still banned there so what
do they do they do what is often called
brand stretching and these brands are
well known internationally there on the
internet they've been on the web and so
while they're not selling cigarettes
they promote the brand through other
logos on t-shirts sports paraphernalia
water bottles canteens and for a while I
was collecting this stuff like I had
hats from racecars and was afraid
somebody would come to my house and
think I worked for the tobacco industry
but this was a very interesting thing
the Thais actually developed a very
robust anti tobacco policy and they had
very high tariffs on Western tobacco
products as did Japan South Korea and
Taiwan in the 1980s and so there was
this question you know were these in
restraint of trade did they vote did
they violate World Trade Organization at
that time known as GATT the general
agreement on tariffs and trade and the
ties were very aggressive about it and
the American tobacco industry went to
the US Trade Representative's this was
in the late Reagan administration the
first Bush one administration and they
said these countries have illegal
tariffs that are restricting the sale of
our products and this was also the time
that Surgeon General coop was mounting
the most aggressive effort in the United
States history against big tobacco so
here you have the American government on
the one hand getting really behind
sidestream smoke restricting smoking in
public places one of coops major Surgeon
General's report was on smoke
as addiction in a press conference he
said smoking is more addictive than
heroin and cocaine and so it's a major
critic of the tobacco industry much
feared by big tobacco at the same time
the US Trade Representative for the
united states are going to Japan
Thailand Korea and Taiwan and saying you
must open your market to American
tobacco products and so what happened
the Japanese the Taiwanese and the South
Koreans were forced by threats of
American trade boycotts to open their
markets to American products and what
happens when you open your your trade to
American products you increase
competition you increase advertising in
Japan cigarettes before this tariff
change were the 40th most advertised
product and after the fall in the tariff
and the introduction of American brands
in Japan they became the second most
advertised product in Japan and what
happens when you have that kind of
intensive advertising and competition
tobacco consumption went up and Japan
went up by 10 percent
within a year especially went up among
women smokers in Japan very few women
were smoking in the mid to late 1980s
well what did the tides do this is a
really fascinating story the in Thailand
where there had been a local indigenous
tobacco control movement they said we're
not raising our calf we refuse to do it
and so what happens in these kinds of
trade disputes it goes to a court in
Geneva where it's adjudicated by the
general agreement on tariffs or trades
or the World Trade Organization and so
the Thai said we have this tariff on
Western products because it's a public
health carrot and there's less smoking
in Thailand because we restrict trade in
American tobacco products and they got
the World Health Organization to come
and testify on their behalf and there's
actually a there's a codicil in
the general agreement on tariffs and
trade known as 20b which says that you
can restrict trade by tariffs for public
health reasons
so they cited this 20 B rule in their
presentation before the trade Court in
Geneva but the American representative
said this is straight out a restraint on
American trade they can have Public
Health processes if they want but they
should appeal equally to American and
Thai produced tobacco products and what
did the court decide the court decided
that they must open their trade to
American tobacco products and it's very
interesting the 20 B rule has three
three levels one is that it must be
necessary for Public Health if you did
it so you might satisfy that when you
say it's a public health mechanism and
the World Health Organization got behind
the ties then you have to you have to
identify that it's the least restrictive
possible measure for accomplishing that
goal harder to demonstrate and then the
third thing is you have to say if you do
have a tariff on tobacco you must be
able to show that it's an effective
public health policy also very difficult
so those three rules are in the interest
of trade over public health but so the
ties were actually forced to open their
markets they were permitted by the
decision of the trade Court to continue
to ban advertising which was in a way a
victory for public health but this has
been the strategy for the companies to
undermine the ban on tobacco advertising
but this is what this is my key point
here is that if we're going to
understand health risks in a global
context they must be understood in the
context of our trade agreements and
trade issues and I don't know if anybody
here has been studying generic drugs and
HIV but the very same rules that in a
way have been significant in restricting
public health interventions for tobacco
have also been utilized to restrict
access to essential medical
so the relationship of Public Health to
trade in a global context is going to be
one of the critical areas of
investigation as we move forward here's
what surgeongeneral coupe said about
this he wasn't allowed to come to any of
the meetings with the US Trade
Representative and he was pretty
outraged he said I feel the most
shameful thing that this country did was
to export disease disability and death
by selling our cigarettes to the world
what the companies did was shocking but
even more appalling was the fact that
our own government helped make it
possible and here you have like the
government acting in completely distinct
ways domestically and in terms of global
interactions here's what here's what
Philip Morris said in any event despite
the lingering tobacco liability cases
and the drop in cigarette consumption in
the United States the tobacco companies
themselves have never been healthier in
part because of the lift of these
tariffs first foreign consumption of
American cigarettes continues to grow
dramatically because of the falling
value of the dollar a reduction in
tariff and non-tariff barriers to
cigarettes and the image of American
cigarettes as the best in terms of
quality and character Japan is now
important u.s. cigarettes and China
shows great potential I did a little
math just to figure out about American
tobacco consumption had fallen from 60
percent or 50 percent to about 20
percent which is about where it stands
today and I asked myself what percentage
of the Chinese market would you need to
replace all the American smokers who had
died or quit and it was about 2 to 3% of
the Chinese market so you can see just a
foothold in the Chinese market
completely puts the companies back
beyond where they were when they were
principally selling tobacco domestically
here's another Philip Morris quote
demographically the population explosion
many underdeveloped countries insures a
large potential market for cigarettes
culturally demand will increase with the
continuing emancipation of women and the
linkage in the minds of many consumers
of smoke
looking manufactured cigarettes with
modernization sophistication wealth and
success a connection encouraged by much
of the advertising for cigarettes
throughout the world so you could rely
on the historical meanings that had been
invented for domestic American tobacco
throughout the world politically
increased cigarette sales can bring
benefits to the government of an
underdeveloped country that are hard to
resist and one of the things we find
about this period of the last 20 years
of the 20th century is that health
ministers would go to cabinet meetings
and say we must control the the
introduction of Western tobacco into our
countries and the economic ministers
would say we need these funds now for
the good of our population in terms of
their immediate health care
infrastructure all needs and so on
so you see enormous tensions within
developing world governments about the
role and character of tobacco profits
this a model that a colleague of mine
develop Julius Richmond - a Surgeon
General during the Carter Administration
very brilliant sort of theorist of
public health and he said to develop
strong public health policies you need
to have a strong stroke social strategy
a political will and a strong knowledge
base and I thought it would introduce
this here because I think it gets at
three of the critical components that
any historical or sociological public
health analysis would need to make of
the introduction of effective public
health policies nothing would have
happened in the u.s. in terms of
reducing smoking if there hadn't been
this excellent scientific knowledge base
about the harms of smoking and yet if
you only had the knowledge base and you
didn't have a social strategy for its
deployment or the political will for its
application you still don't get where
you need to go
so what Richmond was very interested in
was what's the relationship of these
three components I think it's been very
interesting to watch this in the United
States people said in the 1960s and 70s
smoking is your own fault if you do it
so essentially the company said we're
free and clear we've told everybody
we've put it on the label
and so if somebody smokes now when they
get sick it's their responsibility so
some of the social strategist in the
public health campaign against tobacco
in the United States said but what if we
could show that your smoke is harmful to
me then we would change the calculus of
Public Health regulation in a fairly
radical way so what did that social
strategy require that social strategy
required more science about the harms of
secondhand smoke which then created
political will to regulate public spaces
so I think that it you can try this
around different types of issues but you
begin to see the relationship of these
components in thinking about public
health interventions and possibly Public
Health governance so the question might
be what's the use of law in global
Public Health what's the quality of the
knowledge base overall is there
political will to modify the trade in
tobacco which has been such a dominant
aspect of tobacco Commerce and its
implications for the burden of disease
and this is what began to happen in the
early 21st century and a group of
lawyers had the idea that we're
reviewing the World Health Organization
Charter and one of the things in the
Charter it said is the World Health
Organization has the authority to make
treaties and it was now 2003 2004 the
World Health Organization had never
developed a treaty for public health but
treaties were becoming important in
certain kinds of transnational exchange
and in which there were perceived to be
very significant supranational interests
that could not be moderated or affected
by a single nation-state and so there
was a model of protocols what were
called Framework conventions treaties
around certain kinds of environmental
harms and there was this idea in
countries what if we decided we would
have great environmental policy but the
country next door
or didn't do it then what would be the
advantage of investing in environmental
or ecological change if we didn't have a
partner nearby there pollution would
simply be ours and so people began to
think about this notion of global that's
different than some others in which what
are those levels of risk and exchange
that cannot be moderated by a single
nation-state but can only be done
collaboratively through shared
assumptions and values and exchange and
so the idea got proposed well what about
doing this for tobacco and this tobacco
appropriately fit the criteria of
something in which there are those kinds
of exchange or if you're a tobacco
industry executive you say it's really
up to every nation to decide how it
wants to regulate tobacco there's no
there's no characteristic exchange but
one of the things we found was if one
country's advertising and the next one's
not that advertising bleeds immediately
to nearby neighbors and even more so in
an age of the internet and digital
communications if one country raises its
taxes but nearby countries don't then
there are black markets where they're
smuggling of tobacco and one of the
things we know is that the tobacco
industry has been deeply implicated in
smuggling tobacco from high tax to low
tax areas so there were some strong
arguments for thinking about the
movement of the risk of tobacco in a in
a analogous way to thinking about
changes in the environment and that
became the underpinnings of developing
this Framework Convention on tobacco
control this slides too dense but let me
just tell you what some of the key
aspects of the Framework Convention
which the World Health Organization
approved in 2005-2006 there would be
controls on lobbying they would s
countries participating to raise their
taxes to minimal levels
on tobacco they would have rules about
secondhand smoke and the control of
smoking in public places they would
force companies to be transparent about
the ingredients in tobacco across
nationally that there would be higher
expectations about labeling that there
would be programs for cessation programs
to control sales to minors and so they
took what were the key building blocks
of all national tobacco control policies
but said we'll share these at a floor
level and urge all countries to come up
to these minimal levels and then
increase them as we go and this is the
way framework conventions work they have
the series of protocols the protocols
are discussed by the parties they're
commonly agreed to and then the idea is
that they continue to change with time
as these policies develop in specific
national contexts so the World Health
Organization approved at its General
Assembly this Framework Convention on
tobacco control it was developed by two
very brilliant theorists in public
health law Alan Taylor and Ruth Romer
who's a kind of heroic figure in the
history of American public health law
and it was developed with the support of
Gro Brundtland who was the
director-general of the World Health
Organization and a kind of crack team of
creative analysts and public health
policy people at the World Health
Organization one of them was Derek yok
who was a young physician who had
developed a fabulous tobacco control
program in South Africa South African
and had gone to the world World Health
Organization and worked on developing
and promulgating the Framework
Convention on tobacco control and yock I
think is a particularly important figure
because he and some other people were
theorists about the use of law about the
nature of civil societies about
rethinking global governance and what
kinds of structures might go across
nations as of thinking about as opposed
to thinking about national regulatory or
governance structure
so I always have felt that yok was a
pivotal figure in selling this to
Brundtland and moving it through the
World Health Assembly today nearly 170
countries have signed and ratified the
Framework Convention on tobacco control
the only major developed power that has
not ratified the treaty is the United
States and one of the questions that I
think should be put it was put to George
Bush - and now should be put to the
Obama administration is why have you not
advanced the tobacco control protocols
and Framework Convention to the US
Senate for ratification and I think we
know the reasons because the tobacco
companies remain enormous ly strong
these are some of the health warnings
that were on cigarette packages and what
what I'm partially arguing is they
develop strong consensual notions that
push one country and then pushed another
country so these were in Brazil the
United States had very weak labeling the
Canadians developed very strong labeling
and this has promoted Latin American
countries and others to develop strong
labeling this was sort of interesting I
was in Montreal two summers ago and I
was in a pharmacy and I said I'd like a
pack of cigarettes with the cigarettes
cause mouth diseases label and the
pharmacist thought I was a nut because
people have been trading that back for
less offensive label when these first
went into effect and as you may know the
United States labels have not changed
since 1986
there's been no major piece of US
tobacco legislation until two years ago
the new FDA regulations of tobacco and
these are the new labels that will begin
to appear on American - cigarette
packages beginning next year and I'd
like to think I think there are some
things in a merit in the American
tobacco control arsenal that should be
applied
at the same time this is an instance
where some of the things that we've
learned from developing countries and
other countries with much more
aggressive labeling could have a very
salutary impact on smoking rates in the
US and you can see there about eleven of
these they're all pretty dramatic
they're gonna cover a major part of the
tobacco package next year one things we
know about labeling is they it wears out
so by not changing the label since 1986
it's been definitely demonstrated by
public health experts it has no impact
in the United States right now so most
people don't see the labels they don't
know what they say and these will these
will have an impact now I want to take
up just briefly the tobacco industry's
position on the Framework Convention on
tobacco control I'm sorry to give you
such a pros heavy slide but this is what
an advisor to the - I'm Philip Morris
had to say
Philip Mars should be unapologetic about
its advertising and promotion activity
in the third world there's something
patronizing about the World Health
Organization approach to smoking and
health in the third world
waho assumes that people must be saved
from Diamond tobacco by their
governments that they can't be trusted
to make personal decisions about whether
or not to smoke people in the West
despite increased government
interventions make these decisions all
the time and third world leaders
generally resent the implication that
they and their people must be protected
and this has been a crucial trope in
tobacco industry ideology going well
back that people should make their own
decisions and why should governments
intercede in a individual decision about
risk-taking and that really that's what
makes markets great there are a lot of
risks out there and individuals should
make up their own mind and this was seen
as do-gooding the terminology for
example that many of you have heard
about health Nazis that's just not a
term that was made up that was a term
invented in tobacco industry boardrooms
and then they have public relations
experts that help promote that kind of
view of public regulatory
interventions this is a philosopher who
is writing in the Wall Street Journal in
Europe a well-known British philosopher
of public intellectual this is not to
say that tobacco is harmless or that the
trade and it is a good thing it is to
say rather that where the risk of a
product Falls entirely on consumers and
is fully explained to them it cannot be
the business of unelected bureaucrats to
forbid or control it if we lose sight of
this principle then we lose sight of the
truth on which all free societies depend
namely the freedom and risk are
inextricable and whoever assumes the
right to save me from risks is also
assuming the right to limit my freedom
this is a very powerful view very
sharply articulated in the in the
context of the Framework Convention
here's Scruton again by a semantic trick
therefore missus Brundtland and her team
have been able to classify as a
dangerous disease what is in fact a
voluntary activity and a source of
pleasure the risk of which falls
entirely on the smoker actually that's
not true
it's been shown by the World Health
Organization that 60% of all children in
the developing world live in a house
with a regular smoker and we now know
that those are additional aspects of the
burden of disease by the same reasoning
we could link deaths from driving
drinking and junk food to epidemics and
this is one of the things that we think
about when we defined what an epidemic
is and put cars alcohol and McDonald's
on the WHI agenda and I can assure your
cars alcohol and McDonald's are on the
wahi agenda but this was very
interesting it came to light by an email
from scrutinies wife that actually
Scruton was in the employ of Japan
tobacco one of the major producers of
global tobacco and she wrote in light of
this we were wondering whether you would
consider putting up the fee from 4,500
pounds monthly to five thousand five
hundred pounds on the assumption that we
try our hardest to justify this amount
and that you have the right to revise it
downwards if dissatisfied we think we
give good value for money in a business
largely conducted by shysters and shark
but you may not agree with this so this
is a really important kind of document
because in a way you could say there's a
big philosophical debate about smoking
is it an individual behavior or should
it be publicly regulated in some
governance structures but part of this
argument that's so powerful and
broadcast so effectively has actually
been broadcast by the industry itself so
in one sense you think well those are
philosophical or ethical arguments about
the character of tobacco but really it's
it's an argument that has been
articulated and broadcast by the actual
industrial interests that it supports
and there are many instances of this and
partly what I want to suggest is this is
Bernays to the industry became very
acutely aware that it had a public
relations issues that it could deal with
very effectively behind the scenes and
by sponsoring articles in prominent
magazines like the Wall Street Journal
Europe it gets its views out there into
the political sphere in ways that will
affect policy outcomes they hire firms
like this montgo bin Bisco and Duchenne
and they were advising philip morris
about how to undermine the Framework
Convention so here it says examination
of the draft text will help Philip Mars
anticipate the potential protocols that
the Framework Convention will create the
history of Framework Convention shows
that successful weakening of the
language of an article in a Framework
Convention can be easily undermined in
the protocol process the potential
protocols are more important to the
company in the long term than the
Framework Convention itself so what does
Philip marseilles oh we support the
Framework Convention we think that's a
great idea
because they know that the best place to
intervene now how do they intervene they
want they want there to be citizens that
get to participate in the protocol
making party arguing process and very
often those are people who have had ties
to the tobacco industry they're very
some strategic approaches to undermining
these protocols
aside from delaying the adoption of the
Convention the company is best served by
participating in the
development of the agreement which is
what they did it would be in the country
in the company's best interest have the
treaty focus entirely on protecting
children and leaving adult choice
protected so this is you know this is
the activity of global health and
sometimes it's most nefarious way here's
the chairman of British American Tobacco
the Framework Convention is a developed
world obsession being foisted on the
developing world and on and on I don't
want to take too much time with this one
of the strategies they had was spend
more time talking about AIDS develop
AIDS media which will distract from
tobacco as a as a public health problem
here's British American Tobacco again a
clumsy pursuit of global standards can
become a form of moral and cultural
imperialism based on assumptions that
West is best imposing Western priorities
are global solutions of course the
values and priorities of any one country
on another can become a new form of
colonialism so here you have companies
that are imposing tremendous burden of
disease then defining the regulatory
processes but a new form of colonialism
and I think you know what's concerning
about this is how powerful and
potentially effective these kinds of
arguments can be to countries without
strong state orientations or regulatory
regimes these are kinds of things that
Philip Morris is doing now in the US and
I explained that I consider the u.s.
part of this global mix they say we're
supporting you know youth smoking
restrictions here's what you do if your
child is smoking it's become very clear
in public health that the biggest single
risk for kids are there if their parents
smoke but there's nothing in these
pamphlets about that relationship and
the idea that parents might quit if you
decide to quit smoking so these are very
effective they use these in the types of
trials that I testified in they say no
one's more committed if somebody wants
to quit then Philip Mars to helping them
get what they need
to quit so these become very effective
public relations tools even though
they're shown from the kinds of science
of public health assessment that they
don't actually assist people in quitting
if philip morris is helping you quit
cigarettes you're in very big trouble
when the government if Joe Camel they
started camel number nine with these
pink packages obviously with the idea
that they would especially appeal to
women these are being sold globally now
here was one thing I would just wanted
to mention you know I told you Derek yok
was kind of a hero of mine and I think
he's one of the great thinkers I asked
the class to read two of his papers that
were very influential to me so Derek
watt left World Health Organization went
to Yale School of Public Health where he
taught and had a decadal role and then
he left yell School of Public Health and
I started looking where's Derek yeah
today and some of you may know he went
to PepsiCo where he became their
principal vice president for global
relations and here he is pictured in the
center as senior vice president for
global health policy at PepsiCo and I
sort of invite you to go on the PepsiCo
website because PepsiCo in the beverage
industry has learned a lot from the
tobacco industry about how to promote
products that are very high in sugars
around the world and so what they've
done is introduced a range of products
knowing that their sugared products are
their most popular and most aggressively
advertised and most highly sold but by
introducing a range of safer and less
risky products they then say don't
regulate sugared sodas because we are
leaving this up to consumer choice and
we're providing much less risky products
in the marketplace and that's exactly
what PepsiCo has done and I have to say
I don't blame this on Derek yok but it
was real disappointment to lose his
intelligence from public health to now
really advising PepsiCo about how to
orient themselves in a global market so
this is from the PepsiCo website just
pulled this off the
day today whether it's Quaker Oatmeal or
Lay's potato chips consumers around the
world can choose products that are right
for them and good for their families
choices like these along with active
lifestyles make it easier for consumers
to enjoy the foods they like and achieve
the energy bounds they need to lead
active lifestyles and so I have to say I
don't think I would have noticed this
reading this but having spent so much
time following the logic of the tobacco
industry argument I think you can see
there's a very powerful set of
relationships and thinking about the
global market the idea of freedom of
choice the idea of opening trade the
idea that risk is really can only be
assessed by individual consumers and
should not be regulated by governments
so here are people smoking around the
world this is really the problem and
I'll end here is that if consumption
just remains constant as to what it is
today 1 billion people will dive tobacco
related diseases worldwide in the 21st
century a hundred million died worldwide
in the 20th century so we will increase
tobacco deaths
even if consumption only stayed right
where it is by a factor of 10 in the
21st century a billion people and if you
could moderate tobacco even somewhat you
could reduce these figures but it's very
hard given the long time lags tobacco
and the difficulties of cessation to
really reduce this market so it will
involve much more creative strategies
about governance and regulation than we
currently have if we want to impact a
problem as insidious in which are such
powerful industrial interests continuing
to promote the product as there are in
tobacco this is a child in Serbia on
your left are monks in Cambodia a
tobacco salesman in Jakarta Indonesia on
your right are street children in
Shanghai on your left is little boy and
actually there's a story about this name
Sergey Myra and this was taken by
Pulitzer Prize winning photographer in
st. Petersburg in 1993 and the little
boy was just eight years old at the time
and he told John Kaplan the photographer
I only smoke Marlboro cigarettes so what
this what what does this mean to me it
means that given the dimensions of the
problem we need to have far more
creative and robust strategies of global
governance and we have I actually find
myself quite hopeful about a phenomena
like the Framework Convention on tobacco
control even though I'm prepared to
recognize how weak it is in
relationships the resources that will be
brought to bear by the industry but if
nations can participate as civil
societies collaborating and recognizing
the threat that's posed by certain kinds
of trade Commerce and industrial
interests then at least we have the
beginnings of some strategies that we
need to think much more about I actually
think that historians anthropologists
sociologists epidemiologists there's
many fields represented here we'll
really need to collaborate much more
consistently than we have in the past if
we're going to come up with the kinds of
things that really contribute to change
around issues like tobacco so thank you
very much
yes thank you again Alan and if you have
questions I'm sure you will please come
up to the microphone and I have to say
that was really you know amazing
demonstration of how you can use this
tree to look ahead and see it
differently and and at the same time you
know weave in this this common concern
of ours about the the idea of global
governance and you know one of the
critiques for those who speak about
global governance is this question of
accountability and it does seem that the
tobacco industry is is playing on that
idea who elected Gro Brundtland right
and you know who is it it's really
behind these these advocacy networks and
and so on so you know what do you say to
this idea that those who are purporting
to serve you know people in in poor
countries by protecting them from the
export of American cigarettes you know
who do they answer to and why is it that
we should allow them to set the agenda
for all of us right you know the thing
about complex governance structures like
Framework conventions is that in the end
it has to be consistent with national
political democratic processes so even
though the protocols can in a sense
require countries to come up to these
standards it's really a consensual
standard that then has to be it has to
be supported through the internal state
regulatory processes so it's not as if
the Framework Convention can decide
everybody's gonna label cigarettes in
this way and then that actually puts the
labels on the cigarettes what the
framework does is it sets a standard
that then the political processes will
be held accountable to so in a sense
that's the weakness of the Framework
Convention is that it invents standards
that will not necessarily be fulfilled
through all parties to the convention
and I think that's acceptable you know
the question is it seems so ironic for
the industry to say but who's
accountable to tobacco activists because
we actually understand the
accountability of industrial interests
very well industries are accountable
exclusively to their shareholders so to
say that shareholders have a greater
stake in public health processes than
these other forms of formal and informal
governance mechanisms seems to me to be
somewhat hypocritical so you know it's
one thing to voice the argument that
choice is very important but when you
see the industry doing it as an industry
that's one thing when you see the
industry supporting those arguments as
if they are independent then I think it
really undermines their authority to
question accountability so I think the
industry just incredibly sophisticated
and that's the that's the question away
what are the countervailing governance
structures in the face of certain kinds
of capital interests that can be very
detrimental to the public good okay
thank you
I wanted to know since the tobacco
industry has been proved guilty so to
speak in the u.s. why isn't it a slam
dunk for other countries to sue them and
get a lot of money it's a it's a really
good question and unfortunately even
despite the success of the American
tobacco suits most of the funds that
were collected for example by the state
attorneys generals in their cases when
the company settled went to other things
so rather than their some of that money
being dedicated to tobacco control it
went to pay debt in North Carolina paid
for some tobacco warehouses it paid for
the maintenance of golf courses in some
states and so it turned out to be
incredibly unfortunate two hundred and
forty billion dollars collected by the
collective's
state Attorneys General
that now you know merely funds you know
day-to-day operations in the state and
you see the companies really understood
that and they said we can get rid of
these suits the monies won't go to
tobacco control so is again very
sophisticated but the question is what
where does liability fit in a global
strategy and there are some countries
where it will actually be quite viable
there's some Latin American countries
where there are some very promising
litigations against the tobacco industry
but it really has to do with individual
judicial structures and in the United
States we've always had a relatively low
threshold for civil litigation which is
one of the really great Democratic
aspects of the American court system is
that if you had a legitimate complaint
you could bring it against a company at
relatively low cost and get into the
courts there are other places like the
United Kingdom where it's almost
impossible to enter the courts on a tort
so there are these individual structures
and I think when we're doing comparative
global work you would really want to
understand better you know where are the
places where there are opportunities for
tobacco liability litigation to succeed
where is that likely to be secondary
what kinds of legal remedies could you
pursue in the face of a failure of torts
and other things so it's a very good
question because how can the courts be
used more effectively with there's a lot
of people who sort of think that the in
the u.s. the liability phase is over I'm
less clear about that I think there are
some very creative strategies and we may
see some of these strategies move to
other other products everyone left when
some kids sued McDonald's on issues of
the health of their foods how
transparent the calories and fat content
were but what you did see is McDonald's
you know in their corporate structure
responding to that very quickly in some
positive ways by developing changes in
their menu greater transparency in their
nutritional identification so litigation
I think sometimes forces better public
practice and it's one of those threats
how could we use it more effectively
even if you're gonna fail i watch the
tobacco litigation fail and fail but
it's having a tremendous impact in
getting the documents out so the history
that I was able to write was dependent
on litigation that had failed and that
irony really it told a story that has
been used now I think by myself but many
others to effectively galvanize public
health interest in regulating tobacco
that wouldn't have been available
without the suits and the companies kept
saying we're winning but as those
documents began to come out they were in
some aspects that we're losing yes thank
you very much
some years ago C everett Koop said that
as soon as americans found out that the
tobacco companies had lied to them about
the addictive qualities of cigarettes
they would throw their cigarette packs
away and be done with the whole thing
and he he said it was one of the big
disappointments of his life but that's
not what happened
and that the problem of cessation was
one that was actually stronger the
addictive qualities were actually
stronger than he had anticipated I'm
wondering if you could tell us just a
little bit about the history of tobacco
cessation and how successful it is at
this point yes it's a great question and
you know tobacco is one of those
problems that is so dynamic and multiple
that the only types of policies that
really will work will be across a
gradient from individual patient
oriented services to you know strategic
public communications and other
regulatory interventions and cessations
really important and we know that some
people can quit and do quit but we also
know now that for some individuals it is
enormous ly difficult to quit so a quit
is not a constant phenomenon and we now
understand that better for example
people with a code
we're bid psychiatric condition have
much more difficulty quitting people who
are not in strong social networks have a
much greater difficulty quitting so how
could we address those that particular
population this last 15 to 20 percent of
Americans who are smokers that is a
residual very difficult addicted
population that will require stronger
biomechanical and social interventions
and we have available for them now but
there have been other issues for example
we haven't third-party funded a lot of
cessation services we know that some of
the medications that are helpful are not
helpful without therapy or counseling so
there's a lot that we could do to really
address these needs I was I was doing a
little research on smoking in mental
health hospitals it's really interesting
in the 50s and 60s if you behave well
they would give you cigarettes in these
hospitals so one of the rewards was
actually tobacco and there was a lot of
concern what would happen if if certain
mental health institutions went smoke
free and they actually have and I think
it's a great thing because you really
don't want people exposed to you know
who are suffering to be exposed to
additional risks and people can quit
under the right conditions with the
right support and some of that is
pharmacologic some of it is social and
cultural so it really means putting
those things together and we could do
much better and we can and a lot of
those things will be tremendously
beneficial in the developing world as
their health infrastructures become
stronger thanks again for coming to
speak one of the things we have talked
about this summer in the class that's
associated with this lecture series is
thinking critically about historical
analogies and I was wondering if you
could elaborate on how we might think
critically about using the tobacco case
and applied to fast food as well as the
example you mentioned with PepsiCo and I
was wondering what your thoughts were as
well on the possibility that this might
actually be to some advantage to
company's going forward in that they can
point to litigation on fast food as
something that is sort of similar to
what they make their opponents out to be
as somebody whose response is you know
not merited as something that perhaps
trivializes the public health threat of
cigarettes yes it's a really good point
because you know when people sued
McDonald's the industry the tobacco
industry right away said this is what
happens when you get into a litigious
society where there's always someone
else to blame where no one's really
accountable for their own individual
decision making and I get asked that
question a lot like well am i saying
that people who smoke have no
responsibility and they're out of
control and I actually think the goal of
health in a way is giving people as much
autonomy as possible over the control of
their health but that would mean that
you'd have to moderate some of these
industrial interests so it's a little
bit of a misconception the best thing is
is if people can quit but what's the
context in which they can quit it's a
regulatory context that's the context in
which the risks of the product are very
clearly identified and which is
educational and communications ideas
I've been concerned about the story of
tobacco in this way like on the one hand
I wanted to tell it and I thought if I
told it clearly people would see these
strategies more clearly when they were
applied by other industries I think one
of the things we're finding right now is
a lot of industries are studying very
closely what the tobacco industry did
and how they've been so successful and
they're studying in many ways you know
we should be looking for developing
world global markets in places where the
regulatory regimes are becoming more
overt and aggressive in terms of sugared
beverages for example which are not sold
in many elementary schools anymore and
it's been shown that they have an impact
on child and teen obesity we should be
looking to develop worlds where there
are less regulatory regimes and we see
the movement of risk globally from more
highly regulated to less well regulated
places so that's one thing the arguments
about choice and
freedom of individuals to make those
determinations the arguments about
individual Nations should make those
decisions instead of doing it
consensually across nations these are
all things that were very clearly
articulated in the tobacco industry
documents which became widely available
and unfortunately I wasn't the only one
using them
I think the industrial interests of
similar products that have risk have
been using them also so there's been an
emerging literature on sort of the
tobacco PlayBook as it gets called and I
think many people admire how effectively
the tobacco industry responded to what
was perceived in the 50s as a potential
knockout blow to the industry and how
they were able to sustain themselves and
be enormous ly profitable throughout the
second half of the 20th century into the
21st century
despite marketing a product that is
uniformly harmful to human beings it's
it is you know I mean I have to I have
to say it's a remarkable if you know
terribly sobering story and I think that
other industries will learn from it so
you know those of us who are advocates
for public health have to be more
aggressive creative we have to rethink
policies and and strategies and I think
historians among other fields will have
a lot to say about understanding how
these how these structures got to be and
how important they are for the overall
burden of disease so I know that doesn't
completely answer your question but
please hey thank you for your speech and
I'm actually not sure whether you are
the right person for me to ask this
question but I just wanted to have a try
I was thinking maybe it would be
effective policy for Chinese government
to tie up
cigarette smoking with deduction in
their medical bills so if they smoke
they will not get government subsidy on
the medical bill so my question is I
wanted to know whether the current
medicine would take
technology is a very sensitive to early
stage smoking because yeah I see those
pictures away it's very serious you can
you can see the lawns okay but I wonder
whether they can detect the wound needs
about in an earlier stage yes it's
getting easier and better to detect lung
cancer for example sooner
there are biochemical assays that can
show who's smoking and who's not but I
have to say my own perspective has been
not to restrict health services for
smokers and that's been a prominent
argument in the United States it sort of
says because it buys into the idea that
this was an individual risk and
therefore the smoker should be
responsible for what he or she did in
terms of smoking and the way I see
smoking is that it's a behavior that's
been motivated by the companies and the
best way of demotivating it is
regulating the industry as opposed to
potentially punishing smokers and the
reason I say that is that some people
and I'm sure this is true in China are
much more vulnerable to become smokers
than other people they tend to be less
well educated they tend to be of lower
socioeconomic status and the companies
know that their advertising is most
likely to appeal to these target groups
they tend to be young people and so what
happens with most smokers is in the
United States for example is most people
most people who become smokers today
start it when they were 14 or 15 years
old sometimes younger and then by the
time they get to be 30 they're gonna be
have a lot of trouble quitting and if
they're not in a good social network
that has promoted quitting it'll be even
harder and then they'll get sick and
they'll say well we don't give health
services to people who smoked even
though the industry knew that the only
place it was going to get smokers was in
children who couldn't make you know
deeply informed educated decisions so I
think the best policies are the ones
that focus on
striction zuv the product as opposed to
sort of saying we won't provide health
services because by then it's too late
and what you really want to do is is
have interventions that break the chain
of tobacco commerce at an earlier point
in time taxes are very effective so high
taxes on tobacco have been shown to
radically decrease tobacco consumption
well I agree with you that dealing with
the providing of tobacco is a a good
strategy however since those developing
world had already collapsed in terms of
tariffs against American tobacco
products I think if China right now to
increase the tariffs against American
tobacco products I think it might be
difficult it probably would be although
in China you know most of the tobacco
smoked in China continues to be produced
by the Chinese government and this has
been one of the problems in a lot of
developing world countries I didn't have
enough chance to say about it is that
these tobacco monopolies sold a lot of
tobacco especially the Chinese
monopolies which was actually started by
the British American Tobacco Company
talked about colonialism in the 1880s
and 1890s and then Mao seized the
British American Tobacco factories and
made them the Chinese national tobacco
monopoly during the Chinese Revolution
but those companies get a lot of revenue
for other functions of the government so
there are strategies within those
governments of sort of saying and I
think this is happening in the Chinese
government right now is sort of saying
you know we're creating a lot of
disability that we will have health
responsibilities for so maybe we have to
rethink the balance between promoting
tobacco which has been a revenue
producer for the government and
beginning to restrict it but one of the
things that happens is when you when the
tariffs are lower when there is
competition from abroad the monopolies
become much more effective so they begin
to modernize their machine
they begin to advertise more so one of
the things it's like the World Bank was
against monopolies because they found
them economically inefficient in a
global trade but tobacco monopolies
actually restricted the the profusion of
tobacco in important ways but I'm much
more for acting on that production side
than on the side of the individual
smoker Scott yeah sorry I have to cut
off discussion but it's just said we
were around for a bit so we can we can
take it okay go ahead
thank you very much those fantastic talk
my work my PhD work is actually in
Indonesia and I I see a huge number of
primarily males smoking in Indonesia I
find it fascinating is I think some
surveys have put it upwards of 70 or 80
percent of males it's deeply ingrained
within you know it's intergenerational
as you have pictures of children are
smoking primarily boys and it goes into
teenagers some of the groups that I work
with if you don't smoke as a male you're
called ilaria which is a transgender
individual illness it's a stigmatizing
term of course in many cultures in many
parts of Indonesia now I'm wondering if
any public health interventions have
aimed at breaking down and and uprooting
those those norms as the sense of
masculinity and femininity and I'm
wondering if there's anything outside of
litigation or financial incentives
pressures taxes is there any way in
which those can be uprooted and is there
any examples in the US or anywhere else
of those programs yeah this is a really
great question because you know partly
what I've been talking about is is
global and it's it's complicated for us
because on the one hand I think what I'm
arguments we need to take a global
perspective on problems like this and
yet at the same time I think you I think
we really need to understand these very
intricate local meanings of cigarettes
if you were to develop a whole tobacco
control program and there certainly are
you know I spoke to a group of teenagers
in New York City about eight or nine
years ago and one of the students came
up to me afterwards and he sort of said
I didn't have any friends he was 15 he
said I didn't have any
until I started smoking now I have so
many friends and I know I should stop
but you know I built my I built my
friends you know around beginning to
smoke and that's what we do we smoke and
I know it's not good for me and I it
gave me some notion that that it's very
easy for us to see this as a bad
behavior without any social rewards but
in certain cultures in certain
subcultures there can be very
significant benefits to this and to not
understand that preclude some of the
interventions that might help us undo it
I mean one of the things I've noticed in
American tobacco control initiatives is
among adolescents making the industry
the villain is much more effective than
sort of saying you're doing something
bad and so there's been some very
effective local teen and kid campaigns
that really emphasize they're
manipulating us and so I think you know
those psychologies are not universal so
you really need to understand in a
cultures you know such as Indonesia how
is this working and is there some way of
uncoupling the cultural connections that
it currently makes and the meanings that
it has and I watched the meaning of
cigarette smoking change in the United
States from you know from everyone doing
it in film to people apologising for
doing it for people feeling ashamed
about doing it I don't see those as bad
things but if we understood those
processes are there ways to engineer
them in some ways and I think that you
know that's why we really needs very
creative ethnographic and culturally
specific work to understand how smoking
functions in a different culture even
though the product seems universal and
and globally branded as it's put now
so I think that was a great question I
really appreciate that answer as well
fantastic talk I kind of went to a
Probie war on the issue of
stigmatization of the smoker versus
stigmatization of the industry and you
know there is a exchange that you had
mentioned between scott burress and ron
bear in terms of whether we should use
thigma at all as a tool against
individual smokers when it is an
addictive problem and the industry is so
involved with promoting this unhealthy
activity so I'm wondering just if you
could kind of expound upon your I think
will be used in terms of ways what is
appropriate and given given the history
of the role of industry yeah I mean I
think that there's a progression to
these things so for example we could
take outdoor bands as just one example
like I would have started without to our
bands or bands on Jones Beach or
something like that but I'm not adverse
to that now and you know I was walking
through the Columbia campus you know
which I walk through thousands of times
as a student you know what if smoking
was banned in the main quadrangle of the
Columbia campus here on 116th Street
what would be the implications of that
it's a very interesting kind of thought
experiment what if there were just signs
as you enter those gates that say you
know smoking is not allowed you know
within the gated historic part of the
Columbia campus it wouldn't say you
couldn't smoke on Amsterdam at but you
know just in that space and I actually
think that's a pretty good public health
intervention now is it stigmatizing a
lot of people visit Columbia from all
over the world
it says Columbia cares about health that
within this enclosed out outside space
we don't permit smoking and there would
be you know places where you could put a
cigarette out as you enter that space
now is it like that
yes
you can't smoke there that's great yeah
the the I mean I've seen some very
effective anti-smoking bands are they
stigmatizing I think at one time like
the bands were stigmatizing I noticed
for example that nurses hadn't quit in
many health care institutions but the
doctors had and the doctor would come
out a lot of nurses would be smoking by
the doorways and they'd say you know you
really need to quit and you know I
didn't think that was such a great thing
but I wonder you know like spitting on
New York City subways was hot you know
was prominent became you know illegal
became stigmatized is that necessarily
you know a bad thing and is that only
about health in part it is but in part
it's about other things but I think
things have put out powerful public
signals that this is a at the very least
a contested and dangerous behavior you
know for individuals is the state acting
in a you know in a public good way so
you know this was the one thing that
drove the company is crazy they knew
that their their public choice arguments
were very powerful and they said we're
really in danger on the side stream
smoke because it unseats all of our
public choice it's only happens to the
smoker himself and it really undid them
and so I think where you can spread the
notion that smoking is harmful to others
even if it has an edge of stigma it's
something smokers should understand and
it's something that you know the public
should have signals about so I'm not
that sensitive I think certain things
should be stigmatized they're harmful
harmful to self or others I'm sorry I'm
gonna have to make this the last
question or speakers been speaking now
for almost four hours and I'd like to
give my all right first of all I just
really wanted to thank you for the very
wonderful talk on but you've told us how
throughout the years these tobacco
companies have evolved in an almost
Darwin esque fashion to the changing
factors within the environment by
developing such products as light
cigarettes or something like that and
recent years some things like the
electronic cigarettes
have merged as wondering what's your
opinion on the strength of the existing
framework to prevent I guess the spread
of these products yeah it's a it's a
very good and kind of sad question
because I think well part of what I'm
suggesting is that we've really made
some substantial public health progress
and we've seen you know in a relatively
well educated and affluent societies the
ability to significantly reduce smoking
and I see that as the positive side and
then I think the negative side is very
significant that the companies have
understood that those markets remain
significant if compromised and that they
can move to other more vulnerable
markets very successfully and it will
involve strategies that we just haven't
imagined yet and it it really comes into
question you know the character of
markets and health and trade and those
are very difficult issues and I was
thinking about my talk today and sort of
how aggressive it is about industry
interests that spread risks but that is
going to be the contested territory of
public health and population health in
the 21st century it's around generic
drugs and the pharmaceutical industries
it's about essential medications it's
about risks like sugared beverages or
alcoholic beverages it's about many
things and so we're going to need more
robust governance and regulatory
structures if we really want to support
health through societies and I think
we're at a relatively there's a lot that
we've learned but we're at a relatively
preliminary stage in building those
kinds of structures and that's part of
the message I think okay thank you again
Alan Thanks
so so together with my partner in this
program Steve Morse who you've seen many
times here up at the podium I want to
thank you all again for coming and I
hope some of you will come back again
next summer for another year at the
Hertog global strategy initiative so
thank you thank you Steve for being my
partner and and thank you all